so uh anyway here we are another bowl
session as it's called here in our
office with alex and galena
and first of all it's of course
valentine's day today happy valentine's
day happy valentine's day
um i was a little late in booking a
restaurant so all i was able to get was
the 5 15 seating
whew
at least i got something yeah so we're
going out uh tonight how about you guys
special plans uh maybe a romantic dinner
you're hoping or you have already know
about it i know okay good maybe you know
he's waiting for hubby to invite him
all right
in other words your husband's not saying
cook me a romantic dinner no
no that would not be a winner he would
be very very foolish if he tried that
he tried that once before and it didn't
work
he wouldn't dare he wasn't there
and alex you have any plans nothing
special but nothing special all right
um
one thing that i thought we'd talk a bit
about is sometimes you hear people say
all languages are equally difficult
and uh you know i was just just thinking
about korean
and you know after two months of
romanian i could listen to a radio
program about
history
or news and i understood 60 70 of it why
because first of all romanian is
pronounced exactly the way it's written
it's written in the roman alphabet
seventy percent of the vocabulary is
almost identical to italian pronounced
like italian i mean it's easy yeah
korean
i spent i don't know five times as much
time on korean i'm nowhere if i listen
to a podcast about politics or history i
mean i get the artwork so how can you
possibly say that all languages are
equally difficult what's been your
experience with this
now galena you have of course your
english is flawless and now you're
learning french and have you dabbled in
any other how do you find french
compared to english um more difficult
more more difficult but uh
to some degree it's uh it's easy for me
because
many words uh russian words were
borrowed from french so i can recognize
them like corridor and something like
that and there's not many of those uh
yes but yeah the odd one yeah
no but uh in terms of pronunciation and
some grammar rules it's it's difficult
for me
i i mean you mentioned pronunciation i
mean romanian is easier to pronounce
than portuguese so if you're a speaker
of spanish
you know italian is easier even though
spanish is closer to portuguese as i'm
particularly talking about the
portuguese that's spoken in portugal
where they kind of chew up their vowels
it's more difficult
french is more difficult because it's
not written the way it's pronounced
uh
you know and then the writing system is
huge like even like when i went to study
czech even though i studied russian for
a much longer period of time it's more
difficult even now after all the russian
i don't know how many millions of words
of russian i've read it's more difficult
reading in
an alphabet that you're not so familiar
with now i don't know how that affects
russians but i guess they read so much
in the roman alphabet that it doesn't
bother them
or is it still that much easier to read
in the russian alphabet uh yeah i think
it's it's easy it's easier but the
difference may be not so great because
you have so much more exposure right
how about you you dabbled in alex in
chinese yeah
i've dabbled in a few different
languages
french
i learned for longer than chinese
i mean chinese you can
it's not a there's no correlation
really between sound and what you see
right like some people say oh this
radical is the same here but in fact
90 of the time you have no idea right uh
french is also difficult because french
it's difficult when you're listening to
try and transcribe because all these
hidden pronunciation hidden
uh letters that appear in the text but
right you don't say um
that being said i studied french for
four years in high school
and
which is like very part-time not really
focusing that much on it not working
that hard
and then i've studied korean for six and
a half years quite actively in fact much
more actively than i ever studied french
and uh i can definitely read french
faster than i can read korean yeah
easily like there's no comparison well
in french you have
60 of the vocabulary is the same as
english yeah how can that
not be easier
you know totally so
there are some compensating factors in
chinese
the biggest hurdle is learning all the
characters
the you know you talk about russian
russian is difficult because of the
grammar russian people don't realize
that
but the grammar for russian even
it's so complicated
chinese grammar is actually very easy
he's very straightforward now some
purists will come forward and say that
there's this that another but in fact no
it's it's word order is very similar to
english yeah and the grammar is quite
easy but you have tones the
pronunciation issue and you don't have a
phonetic script
so no the languages are not all equally
uh difficult yeah
i would say i agree
yeah
so we agree i wonder what people out
there think yeah
anyway happy valentine's day
happy valentine's day okay bye